all right my talk at the table is about
schools reopening this fall with daily
coronavirus cases increasing in dozens
of states
teachers all across the country are
voicing concern about the health risks
while most teachers agree that
face-to-face learning is better for
students many also wonder at what cost
a study by the kaiser kaiser family
foundation found that about one in four
teachers one in four
have a condition that puts them at a
higher risk of serious illness
from the virus so what we did is we
asked a diverse group of teachers from
four states
about how they feel going back c-a-p
my name is carla reyes i am a special
education teacher
i am a middle school science teacher at
a small private school in minneapolis
minnesota
my name is dr kai rush and i am a high
school teacher
in clearwater florida
i am an esl teacher in dallas texas
i definitely want to get us back into
school safely there are kids who are in
unsafe places
and school is their safe place to be
i want to see my students smiling faces
in front of the classroom
but do i want students to come back i
want them to come back
safely not all schools have soap
not all schools have potable water
there's a lot to consider when you're
reopening
school buildings where hundreds of
people are coming into contact with each
other every day
i feel very uneasy returning to
face-to-face instruction
because i am putting my children at
risk of contracting covert 19.
going back to school is not going to
mean
going back to school the way we remember
it being
we are going to have reduced class sizes
we are going to have distancing the less
they get close to each other the better
everything is going to be different and
that is
okay let's talk about this the federal
government and city governments need to
step
up and invest in education and all the
different guarantees to make sure
that we don't die i have underlying
conditions
and i like to support my students but if
i
pass from this disease i won't be able
to
support my students or my young adult
children we did not get into this
profession for the money
we got into this profession because we
love kids
and while you're not there we're there
and we want to make sure that they have
the best environment possible
before going back
[Music]
you